CRAIG WILEY: Hi,
my name's Craig,
and I'm the Director of
Product Management for Cloud AI
Platform here at
Google Platform.
Today, I'm going to be
talking to you about how
to create value with the breadth
and depth of our AI platform.
Creating value with
the platform simply
comes down to putting the best
of Google's AI technologies
to work for you and
for your company.
What does this mean?
Fundamentally, this
means, how can we
map your business strategy
to the right AI absorption
strategy?
We'll talk about
the different ways
that Google helps you deploy
AI without compromising
on flexibility, speed,
quality, or scale.
And finally, we'll
talk about some
of the customers
that have transformed
their businesses by tapping
into the innovation from Google.
As I think about AI,
fundamentally, AI only
does two things.
One, it helps you
grow your market,
increased subscribership,
increase users,
increase their spend, or
increase their conversion.
Or it helps you in the back
end drive efficiencies,
reduce costs, drive out
waste from the system.
Together, these two
capabilities allow
you to achieve previously
unimaginable results
for you and for your company
using this critical technology
AI is not limited to this
business or that industry.
Opportunities to
use AI can be found
in every vertical,
whether it's retail,
our capabilities in
health, financial services,
things like lending or
anti-money laundering, media
and entertainment, or
industrial manufacturing
with things like visual
inspection capabilities,
or public sector.
All of these are rich
with opportunities.
All of these are areas that
we're helping and work on
with AI.
As you think about AI
investments and AI absorption,
when you think about
what Google offers,
you can really break it
down into three levels
of investment.
The first is, AI out of the box.
This is very low-investment,
very quick to market,
but doesn't come with
a lot of customization.
The second is
deploying custom AI.
This, on the other hand,
does allow for customization.
It takes a bit more
effort, but it's still
very quick to market.
And lastly is building
end-to-end AI.
This is when you and the
data scientists you work with
invest to build your own bespoke
models for areas where this
will be critical
to your company's
strategic innovation or your
differentiation in the market.
We can think about these three
levels with this example.
The first example of the
AI right out of the box
would be something like
optical character recognition.
You could imagine simply
calling our Vision API
to quickly and easily read the
documents that you may have.
Second would be something
like, potentially,
content classification.
This is an area where "The New
York Times" invested with us
on using AutoML to quickly
and easily classify
their entire content library.
And then finally, we come
to actual, pure insight
generation, deep investments
that provide unique benefit.
This can be seen wonderfully
with Kaggle, an organization
that we run that
has competitions
for data scientists
and the work they've
been doing seeking to
extract critical findings
from the academic literature
around COVID and SARS viruses.
These three levels
of understanding
can be seen in our
products as well.
At the first layer, we
see pre-trained APIs.
These require no real work from
you to-- all you need to do
is integrate with the API.
No data science is
needed from you.
Instead, you can simply
get your image labeled,
get your document understood, do
entity extraction or sentiment
analysis on your document.
Or in this case, you can see
using pre-trained Video APIs
to track movement or track
an object across frames.
Second would be
customer AI with AutoML.
With this capability-- say our
models don't have the objects
you need labeled.
You want specific fish labeled,
not just "that's a fish",
but you want to know
what species it is.
You can take your own photos,
quickly and easily label them
with our data labeling
service, and then move them in
and train your own AI
model with no code having
had to been written.
And finally, for those
more powerful models
or more interesting
and bespoke use cases,
we offer the full end-to-end
capability with our core tools.
You can think of it this way.
Across the top of the stack, we
have our applications, Vision
and Video, Conversation,
Language, and Structured Data.
So whether it's
labeling an image
or working with
video, whether it's
speech to text, text to
speech, or setting up
a conversational bot, whether
it's translation, or entity
extraction, or
sentiment analysis,
you have all of your needs
with our language capabilities.
And finally, with
Structured Data,
you can build models
on your structured data
without Python or any
sort of coding required.
Then beneath those
applications we
have the core tools designed to
help the data scientists build
the powerful models they want
to both explore and build,
whether it's notebooks as
a service, data labeling,
training as a service,
prediction as a service,
all of the critical
components you'll
need to ensure that you're
building the best AI.
We're excited to announce
some new capabilities coming.
For example, later
this year, we'll
have new, improved
workflows for AutoML
within the console, a
fully integrated experience
no longer requiring you to make
specific decisions and choices,
but instead making it all
easy right out of the box.
You can see that
with our stack you
can start by creating
a data set and then
quickly and easily,
with no code required,
move all the way through to
a model deployment, putting
your model into production,
ready to be called in a highly
autoscaling environment.
Now, for those that wish to do
something more sophisticated
or who wish to build
their own model,
they'll have the full
capability to do so as well.
As we move beyond AutoML, one
primary area investment for us
has been machined
learning ops or MLOps.
In this area, nothing has
been as exciting to us
as what we've seen customers
do with our managed pipelines.
Using those managed pipelines
as well as a feature store,
continuous monitoring of
models that are in production,
and metadata to
help make decisions,
customers will now be able
to support both a fully CI/CD
capability, as well as to
start creating pipelines that
will support much more
sophisticated operations
such as quickly and easily
retraining your model
once skew or drift is detected.
These pipelines--
what they do is
they allow you to take
your monolith of code
that you've used
to build this model
and break it down into each
of the individual components.
Now it's much more easily
debugged and understood,
as well as these
components can be
saved for future model usage.
And in the future, when
you are building a model,
instead of starting
with a blinking cursor,
you can simply go in
pipelines and start
pulling in the most
commonly used pipelines
down into your model
to use for things
like extracting data, validating
data, or evaluating the model.
These capabilities
significantly reduce
the time of experimentation.
We had one customer
telling us that they
have increased their
rate of experimentation
by 7x using this technology.
We couldn't be
more excited to see
how your company will use this.
Finally, as is critical to
any service of this type,
metadata management
is a key piece
of what we believe is
needed to effectively run
a MLOps environment.
Whether that's the automatic
metadata logging from our
posted services or
custom metrics that you
may want to device, both are
quickly and easily captured
and then can be used for
things like compliance, MLOps,
continuous training and
continuous delivery,
or experimentation development,
model and artifact comparisons,
as well as improved
ML reproducibility
and explainability.
The compliance story here
is an interesting one.
It allows you to do previously
very difficult tasks,
things like-- imagine if a
customer said, hey, please
remove me from your records.
All you would have to do
is remove the customer
from the data set in
question or from all
of the data sets
that they're in,
and then with pipelines
and ML Metadata,
you could very quickly
and easily auto retrain
just by determining the fact
that the data set had been
changed, automatically
retrain the model
and redeploy the model
without a human ever
having to write code to do so.
We're proud of our AI Platform
because our AI Platform
does three things really well.
One, it meets our
users where they are.
Two, it quickly deploys the
highest quality AI, and three,
it allows you to
scale and streamline
not a AI in unbelievable ways.
Meeting customers
where they are?
What does that mean?
Well, as you can see
here, I think we all
fall somewhere on the spectrum
of skills and capabilities
within machine learning,
and whether you're
someone who's just starting
out or whether you're
someone who is already
comfortable with the most
sophisticated tooling, we
have solutions for you.
When we talk about meeting
customers where they are,
there's two companies that
are interesting to call out.
The first is cruise.
Cruise is an autonomous
vehicle company
making tremendous
strides in moving
to a world where my
son will never have
to get his driver's license.
With this, Cruise builds models,
and we have worked closely
with them on optimizing
their environments
and optimizing their TensorFlow
capabilities to decrease
their training times so that
they can more quickly and more
easily cycle through
experiments and move
towards a world in which
cars are fully autonomous.
Now, on the other side
is the city of Memphis.
The city of Memphis is
not traditionally known
as a tremendous machine learning
powerhouse, but in this case,
they were actually building
a model very similar to ones
that Cruise has, no
doubt, had to build.
The city of Memphis
wanted to understand
where they had in the
most problematic potholes,
so they used AutoML to
build a pothole detector
and, sure enough, we're
able to save $20,000 a year
in the reduction
in claims costs due
to these unaddressed potholes.
As you can imagine,
these two customers
come with very different
skills and expertise,
and both were able to find
tremendous value with Google
and its Platform.
We do seek, as I said, to
meet customers where they are.
So for example, our AI
Notebooks-- not only
do they come
prepared for the use
of classic or traditional ML
frameworks such as TensorFlow
or PyTorch, but they also
have data analytics capability
so that you can get a big
data image with things
like Apache Beam
pre-installed so
that you can quickly and easily
manage your own data cluster.
Explainability is at the heart
of understanding our machine
learning.
We believe heavily and have
invested heavily in this space.
As you can see at
the top of the slide
are images of
explainability showing
what pixels in
particular the model
may have used to
render its judgment.
Down below on the slide is a
picture of feature importance
from a tabular use case.
Both of these provide
tremendous value
to data scientists in both
understanding why the model is
doing what it's
doing, as well as
ensuring that the model is doing
what it's supposed to be doing.
We don't think of explainability
and explainable AI
as some separate field that can
only be used by the experts.
We believe it's
central, and as such,
we include it with every
prediction in our prediction
service.
We simply publish all of
the explaining results
in the same blogs we
publish your inferences
so that you can go
back and look to see
if you're experiencing
unexpected drift or skew so
that you'll know when it's
time to retrain the model.
Not only do we like to meet
customers where they are,
but we ensure that
we can quickly
deploy the highest quality AI
for easy business outcomes.
This might be in the area of
sight, language, conversation,
or with structured data.
In the area of sight, we're
excited to work with Box.
Box is using our Vision API
to help their customers manage
and gain insights
from their image files
and speed up image-centric
processes and workflows.
Whether it's the work
that Box is doing
or whether it's image
and video search
or industrial inspection,
our Vision capabilities
are unparalleled in the market.
Next would be translation, the
natural language capabilities.
Whether it's entity extraction,
document classification,
sentiment analysis, or in
this case, translation,
Bloomberg is a company
that sells information,
and for Bloomberg to be able
to quickly and easily sell
that information in whatever
language their customer speaks
is a critical capability.
You can imagine how breaking
down the divide of languages
might be beneficial
to your business.
Next was speech, voice,
and conversational bots.
Whether it's speech
to text, text
to speech, video transcription,
voice commands, all of this
is made possible with
these capabilities,
and we're excited about the work
we've done with Domino's using
Dialogflow so that they
could meet all of their goals
and milestones as they quickly
and easily deployed a model
to allow customers to
quickly and easily order
through the use of a
conversational bot.
Finally, it comes down
to structured data.
Structured data is what
many of our businesses
run on, whether it's
in our data warehouse
in the business systems
we may have running.
Now, usually when we talked
about machine learning
and we talk about very complex
and kind of very important
use cases.
Sometimes, though, it's
OK for AI to be fun,
and this is one of those models.
We partnered with Fox Sports,
and they used our AutoML Tables
capability, our structured
data capability,
to build a model that would
predict when the next wicket
would fall in cricket.
Now, for those who
aren't cricket fans
or for those who are, this may
not seem all that exciting,
but I will say that they
increased their app usage.
They also increased
viewership, as well as
reduced a number of critical
cost metrics and customer
attainment because customers
were so interested and curious.
Now, all of a sudden,
when I'm watching,
I can simply pay attention
to the part of the match
that I know is going
to be relevant,
or I may simply want to tune in
to see how well the AI actually
predicts the outcomes.
Finally, the ability to scale
and streamline with ease.
This fundamentally
comes down to Google
passing over many of
its well-built systems
so that you can use
them in your environment
so that you have the
same power of scale
that Google brings to the table.
Nothing shows this
better probably
than Etsy, who,
when joining GCP,
realized that they
wanted to sort through
and index over 40
billion images.
Working with us, we were able
to help them increase efficiency
by 15% in doing this.
As I mentioned
before, AI Notebooks
are a critical day
that many of our users
interact with our services.
I can think back
to the days when
managing a machine learning
team and how many of our data
scientists at the
end of the day when
packed their laptops into
their backpack and head
home for the evening with
their notebooks saved locally
and probably a significant
amount of data saved locally.
With our Cloud Notebooks
available to you,
that's never again a concern.
Our Cloud Notebooks come with
tremendous levels of security,
including data
exfiltration capabilities
so that you know that both
your code and your data
is safe when your employees
are using Cloud AI in our AI
Platform Notebooks.
Finally, our AI Platform
Prediction service.
Our AI Platform
Prediction service
allows you access to some of
the most cutting edge hardware,
things like NVIDIA's T4 GPUs.
It automatically logs
all of your inferences,
the incoming payload
of information,
as well as those
explanatory variables,
and we log all of
that in BigQuery
so that you have quick
and easy access to doing
some of the analysis on it.
Finally, it scales
automatically with traffic.
All you have to do is tell
us what kind of processor
you want running it
and how high up you
would want us to scale
if the traffic comes,
and as the traffic comes,
we will automatically
add those resources
so that you're only
paying when you actually
are seeing that traffic.
As I mentioned before,
AI Platform Pipelines
is a transformational
technology for many teams.
Seeing a 7x increase in
the rate of experimentation
all of sudden makes
problems that were
previously unsolvable solvable.
Now all of a sudden work
that would have taken me
a week may take me a day or
work that may have taken me
months may take me only a week.
With the power of that
kind of velocity increase,
you can only imagine
the capabilities
that your machine
learning or data science
team may be able to affect.
TensorFlow Enterprise.
TensorFlow Enterprise
is uniquely
available on Google Cloud.
TensorFlow Enterprise
does three things.
First of all, it gives you
cloud scale performance
with highly optimized
binaries to allow things
like increased I/O speed so that
you can see improved training
or prediction.
Also, it's used in all
of our managed services
so you know that if
you're using training
as a service or
inference as a service
you're protected by
TensorFlow Enterprise.
I say protected because the
third aspect is support.
Many of us have-- many
have concerns about using
open source in production.
Can you trust that it will be
well-supported with security
patches and bug fixes?
We're excited to say that
with TensorFlow Enterprise,
we extend the one
year of support
that TensorFlow gives to
three full years of support
so that you, your IT
department, and your business
can be comfortable ensuring
that this software is fully
protected from
security and bug fixes
for the full duration of
the life of your model.
All of this comes back
into the AI platform.
Whether it's the applications
for Vision, Conversation,
Language, and Structured
Data, or whether it's
the core services of
notebook as a service,
or training as a
service, or pipelines
that you may want
to use, all of it
we are excited to
partner with you
to build models that go
beyond your expectations.
Finally, to wrap
it all up, first,
map your business objectives
to a relevant AI strategy.
Don't ask how this
technology can help you.
Figure out what you need
help with, and then let's
figure out the right
technology to use.
Second, partner
with a company that
has tremendous experience
deploying AI at scale.
We have learned
from our mistakes.
We have learned of them already.
You don't need to relearn them.
Finally, plan for the
end-to-end AI life cycle
beyond just the model training.
By using pipelines,
you have the capability
to create a full CICD system,
a system that will relearned
learn as soon as the model
starts to become sale
or starts to give
irrelevant results.
Google has been called out
by a number of organizations
for our leadership
in machine learning.
You can see here in Forester's
Wave for their computer vision
platforms that they've
named Google as a leader.
Similarly, in Gartner's Magic
Quadrant Cloud AI's Developer
Services, Magic Quadrant, Google
was named a leader in 2020.
With awards across
the industry, we
are very proud of
what we have built
and very excited to work
with customers like you
on building and deploying
new and exciting models.
With that, I would like to
allow one of our customers
to speak for a
moment on how they've
unlocked the value of
AI with Google Cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
CRAIG WILEY: We're
very lucky to get
to work with Cardinal
Health, and we're
very lucky to see
some of the solutions
that they have been
able to deploy.
With that, here
are some resources
if you're interested and
would like to learn more
about our AI products or
about our build and use
AI capabilities.
Thank you for your time
today, and I look forward
to meeting you and hopefully
working with you on deploying
exciting AI for your business.